[Music]
up next we have a christopher in
birmingham
hey christopher welcome to the show
hey guys thank y'all for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
um so a bit of a of a long story it's
not as much of a success story as the
last couple of calls no it's okay um
but um i'm a 26 year old father i have a
one-year-old and my son is due in two
weeks oh congratulations
thank you thank you very much i'm
extremely excited
um
but anyways we're we're struggling
pretty pretty hard financially i've
tried to do
as much as i know how to do as far as
making an
excel spreadsheet you know budget and
trying to see make sure where everything
goes and make sure everything's
allocated yeah where it should go and
i just i always seem to come up to come
up short
we had
from where we bought our house in august
we had a consolidation loan to try to
make sure that we could get everything
into one thing
and then
and then after the baby was born life
just kind of happened all at once and
then
the consolidation loan just became too
much
so i ended up having to sell my prized
possession which was my truck
that i had built from the ground up
basically sold it and paid off the
consolidation loan and a little bit of
outstanding debt and
i've still got some credit card debt
left
but for some reason it just seems like
every every month every week that i'm
doing the spreadsheet
you know i'm coming up with next to
nothing extra to try to snowball
on these credit cards and much less put
back into savings
and it's just it's just a real it's
overwhelming a real gamble every month
and it's extremely overwhelming
um
my dad
bought dave's book and
you know he's been trying to help me
through it and we're just you know i
don't know where else to turn other than
just kind of go with my hat in my hand
and
and ask for help oh well christopher
you're doing a great job let me just say
that it's a lot right now i mean how old
are you guys
i'm 26 my wife is 29. i'm just i want to
get a handle on it before yeah before it
gets out of control and we want to have
you know the ability to
we want to have the ability to move back
home and enjoy life and do things for
our kids well that we never would expect
that we could do absolutely and you will
be able to and that's the great thing is
that first
motivation point is your why and that
you're sick and tired of being sick and
tired this is the breaking point this is
where people get where they're like all
right i am willing to do whatever it
takes
to turn this around so christopher how
much do you guys make a year
um i i don't know the math on that 100 i
know i make
our net
every month is roughly 35 to 38. she's a
manager in retail okay so her hours kind
of fluctuate a little bit and they're
fluctuating a lot especially with the
late stage of her pregnancy
and doctor's appointments and stuff like
that but my i'm on salary so i make
uh i make right at 2400 a month by
myself take home pays about 45 grand a
year
somewhere around there yeah
which 45 okay so christopher i'll just
give you just the stats that the average
household income dual income was 65 last
year so you guys are living below
average when it comes to just a combined
household income
um what kind of job what kind of work do
you do
i'm an athletic trainer i work in sports
medicine okay cool
at a local
gym or high school i work for a local
it's a
i work for a physical therapy company um
but they outsource the us athletic
trainers to be
a full-time care at the like local high
schools or colleges i work at a local
high school to provide health care for
the kids okay um and what what's your
work how many hours a week are you
working
i'm working
right around
it fluctuates during football season i'm
working right at 60 hours a week and
then during
uh
not football season i'm probably right
around 25 to 35. okay
how much debt do you guys have currently
um we have a little over 12. okay
do you think once you got out of debt
that you would find that margin
are these payments killing that margin
because you said you're doing the budget
but there's nothing left of the month is
that because it's going back out to
payments on the debt yeah are there
other issues everything's going out the
it's going out the payments like
it's going out towards is your mortgage
too high credit cards
but my mortgage is fine i have i'm able
to make the mortgage every month um
what's the mortgage what percentage of
your budget is your mortgage
uh percentage uh what are you guys
paying for your mortgage yeah well yeah
we'll pay it we're paying 9.77 for it
okay so that's reasonable considering
your take-home pay that's not the
problem i'm just looking to see where
the problems are at because when you do
the budget there's more
there's just a lot of money like little
payments and stuff going out all over
the place with i've got three credit
card payments we've got daycare that
comes out every
every uh week it's 180 a week for
daycare um and then we've got hospital
bills from where my last one was born
and we're gonna end up racking up more
from this new one
okay and this all adds up to 12k all of
your debt credit cards medical bills
or is there more
yeah other that's that's everything
other than my wife's car payment
oh what's the car loan
uh the car loan i think she's down to
9 500.
okay
left on it but the payment is uh the
payment is 294.
okay and that's on top of the
12. yeah so we're looking more like 22
000 in consumer debt
yeah
now i'm starting to get a real picture
of where the struggle's coming from
yeah
well uh there's a few things you can do
obviously we need to get rid of this
debt and having those payments freed up
is going to help you guys immensely but
the other thing you need to do i would
get onto every dollar instead of the
spreadsheet and see if that helps you
because we'll gift you the premium
version that's inside of ramsay plus
along with financial peace and so you
guys can track it it'll be connected to
your bank and you need to really stare
at every penny going out going where
could we cut where could we cut how do
we bring more money in that's how you're
going to create that margin to
do the debt snowball and to christopher
i would say upping your income so really
the two ways that you're going to see
movement the most
is cutting the budget but there may not
be a ton there could be some to cut for
sure but there may not be a ton just
seeing what you guys make a month
knowing all of your expenses from
daycare food everything so but the the
other end of the of the spectrum is your
income
and that's what i would wonder is hey
you got i mean you said during you know
during certain times of the year you're
working crazy hours versus it goes down
when it's not when you're not in season
and so it's either
looking at christopher which could be
very uncomfortable for you but just like
hey what's a totally different job
because the what people are paying right
now
for workers and for wages is
is it's insane it's insane and so what
what would it look like to go to a
completely different industry
just to get your head above water even
if it's something that you don't really
want to do you don't love it but they're
paying
50 grand a year yeah um
hospitality retail i mean they're paying
15. because this 45 000 is household
incomes that includes your wife's which
means you're making even less than that
so you could be you know i'm not sure
what you're making but it could be
around thirty five thousand
thirty thousand so um i just think you
could you could be making more and again
this is not a forever move but there is
these extreme measures that you guys are
gonna have to take because you're kind
of in an extreme situation you guys have
have a lot of debt again your shovel's
not huge
um with your income and so there's
something to be said about man what if
we just turn the tables and i know you
have a new baby coming so maybe you wait
until that until mom and baby and
everyone is good and then maybe you just
make a leap and say hey for 18 24 months
we're just gonna go crazy and we're
gonna cut the budget we're gonna do
every dollar and stick to it i'm gonna
see what extra job i can either take on
or maybe even move
industries completely and just say man
i'm gonna just take a higher paying job
for now
um just to get some traction and then
you could look up you know in eight 24
months and be like okay we can breathe
again this feels good and then i can go
back and do what i love um when it comes
to this but maybe there's something even
within your skill set
a different position that you could do
but that income i would look to see
getting that up that's what's going to
help you get your head above water